- I'm very, very predicated
on running a marathon
in a world that I think is
running a sprint.
I think when we think about 2014
and I think about
the entrepreneurs
in this room and the marketers
and the brands that I work with
we live in a world where
people lack patience.
We just don't have patience
and I promise you that
if you're able to whether it's
financially or emotionally
put yourself in a position
to have patience
you have a far better
chance of succeeding.
Your decision making
path becomes far
clearer and you build
much more leverage
to actually build wealth or
work-life balance or
legacy or whatever makes you tick.
(techno music)